Jim Jones leader of the People's Temple
has come to symbolize the ultimate in
sleazy evil cult figures through a
forceful personality charm and genuine
good works he managed to draw a massive
following and lead them like a
modern-day Pied Piper to the jungles of
Guyana there he promised them a
modern-day Garden of Eden what they
found was confinement mental and
physical control and enforced suicide in
this week's by graphics we dive into the
life of the real Jim Jones James Warren
Jones was born on May the 13th 1931 to
lanessa Putnam and Jim Jones senior in
Crete Indiana the older Jim was a
disabled War veteran then Atta was some
15 years younger than her husband and
the marriage was not a happy one Jim was
often away working on road crews leaving
Lunetta
isolated and lonely in Crete she
certainly didn't help her cause though
with her unsocial manner she smoked
cursed and voiced obtuse opinions at
every opportunity Mineta
had never wanted to be a mother the
addition of a child to the family only
increased the stress the Jones were
facing shortly after the child's birth
Jim suffered a complete nervous
breakdown unable to work any longer the
finances became dire leading to their
eviction from the family farm the
homeless family were taken in by Jim's
relatives in the small town of Lynn
Indiana Lynn was a conservative orderly
town with the vast majority of the
townspeople of being churchgoers the
town also had a prominent Ku Klux Klan
membership the Joneses lived in a
derelict Shack that lacked plumbing when
young Jim began school at the age of six
his mother took a factory job this
provided the child with the freedom of
before and after school to roam the
streets he was a needy child who was
terrified of his father finding it
difficult to make friends he spent a lot
of time alone reading often the child
could be seen wandering around town
looking disconsolate elderly widows
around town felt sympathy for the young
wife and would invite him in for a piece
of cake the boy was so polite that he
soon won them over it was through one of
these local matriarchs that Jim got his
first exposure to religion by the way of
the Church of NASA
Jim was constantly attentive even
quoting scripture back to the elderly
woman to his mother's ambivalence Jim
began attending church with the old
woman he hung on every word coming from
the preacher's mouth he also showed an
amazing ability to recite sermons and
quote lengthy biblical verses but Jim
was not exclusively committed to the
Church of Nazarene his natural
inquisitiveness caused him to attend
every denomination in town during the
week he would wander into the woods and
prop himself up on a stump where he
would proceed to deliver fiery sermons
of his own to the local forest animals
this was pretty far outside of a Normand
was just one reason why people would
remember young Jim Jones as a weird kid
his great interest in religion led to an
equally obsessive fascination with death
there were also other things that set
Jim apart from the other kids in Lynn he
cried a lot and he also swore far too
much he would also steal candy from the
local store further his odd religious
obsession led him to come out with all
sorts of strange things such as that he
was being held down by the Angel of
Death by the age of nine Jim was
claiming that he had special powers one
day he climbs on a roof and called down
for everyone to watch him fly cattle
vaulting himself from the roof he
promptly fell to the ground and broke
his arm about that same time Jim took to
wandering around town and collecting
roadkill in order to give each dead
animal and elaborate funeral the other
kids looked on to this with a morbid
fascination Jim was 10 years old when
America entered the Second World War
while all of his schoolmates spent their
recess playing as Marines or GIS he
insisted on playing the Nazis
particularly their leader Adolf Hitler
with whom he was absolutely enraptured
he even went so far as recruiting
younger children and telling them into
mini stormtroopers when they did not do
step high enough he would whack them
with a twig when he became a teenager
Jim's new favorite topic changed from
religion to sex he established himself
as the young people's authority on the
subject and would set up court on his
porch to teach the facts of life in
minut detail to a near audience his
mother was happy for him to share his
dubious knowledge but the parents of the
other children well they were rather
incensed at high school Jim set himself
apart not just by his strange beliefs
and by his strange actions but also
his dress rather than the casual dress
that was normal he wore his Sunday best
every single day he also never spoke
unless he instigated the conversation
however he did love to engage his
teachers in debates attempting to
highlight his superior intellect now
although not in any sense a talented
sportsman Jim was an exceptional
organizer at the age of 14 he
established a baseball league but during
one team meeting some kids saw Jim drop
a pet dog from his loft to its death
after that the players they became
scared of him and the league fell apart
by the early 1940s Jim senior had become
a hopeless alcoholic his body was now
ruined and he had suffered a stroke that
left him unable to speak legibly
lanessa took another man a secret that
was not so secret in the small town
inevitably the marriage irrevocably
broke apart and Jim and lanessa were
divorced in 1945
lanessa took Jim and moved to Richmond
Indiana while attending high school Jim
worked the night shift as an orderly at
the Reed Memorial Hospital in December
of 1948 he graduated with honors which
was quite an accomplishment for a
17-year old who was also working a full
time job
[Music]
it was while working at Reed memorial
that Jim met quartered and fell in love
with a young nurse by the name of
Marceline Baldwin Marceline was
entranced by Jenna who was four years
her junior and the couple were married
in 1949 together they moved to
Indianapolis Indiana in Bloomington
Marceline found work as a nurse while
her husband attended but the University
the couple they now found themselves
living in the heart of Ku Klux Klan
country and it was in the midst of this
redneck country that Jim developed a
passion for two things racial
integration and socialism in the spring
of 1952 Jim accepted a position as
student pastor at Somerset Methodist
Church he excelled in the role and
quickly set up a Youth Center which was
open to children of all faiths he soon
recognized that the way to attract
crowds and therefore to increased church
donations was to adopt a flamboyant
Pentecostal style and make faith healing
a central part of his performances these
performances began to gather wider
attention and before long he was being
invited to preach at conventions and
assemblies throughout Indiana and the
surrounding states regular services were
held at Elmwood temple in Cincinnati
Ohio where he would invite those
suffering from ailments to come forward
for the laying on of hands he even
traveled as far afield as Los Angeles to
participate in a healing convention by
the mid 1950s Jones was filling the
churches with his traumatic healing
sermons at each one he insisted that the
audience be completely integrated and
that black members of the congregation
set up front facts which further
ingratiated him to local black people
it was his insistence on racial
integration within his flock that led to
a split with Jim's church employer
churches in Indianapolis at the time
were strictly segregated and Jim's
allowance of blacks was causing real
problems Jim he quit and discussed and
set up his own community unity Church
this soon morphed into wings of
deliverance which was renamed in 1955 as
the People's Temple Full Gospel Church
from the start Peoples Temple grew large
crowds of both black and white
parishioners the healing dramas were
still the highlight of every sermon but
Jim's prime concern appeared to be
building a truly racially integrated
ministry in recognition of his efforts
to achieve racial harmony Jim was
appointed in 1960 by Indianapolis mayor
Charles Boswell the mayor has intended
his role to be low profile but Jim
immediately took to the limelight
appearing on TV and radio programs
dramatically proclaiming let my people
go
Jones threw himself into the civil
rights movement through his efforts of
churches restaurants amusement parks and
movie theaters they were all integrated
in 1961 Jim collapsed as a result of
over exhaustion he was mistakenly taken
to a black Hospital but when the mistake
was identified he refused to move he
even took to making the beds and
emptying the bedpans
sick black people in the wards this
caused publicity which directly led to
pressure on hospital authorities to
desegregate the wards now not
surprisingly whites controlled churches
and businesses were highly critical of
this upstart preacher who dared to
challenge the status quo threats were
received a swastika was painted on the
wall of the People's Temple church
building and a dead cat was tossed at
Jim's house throughout the 1960s the
Joneses adopted three children of Korean
descent Jim referred to these children
as his rainbow family in an attempt to
extend the rainbow family he also
encouraged members of his congregation
to likewise adopt war-torn refugees now
in the early 1960s Jim he became
obsessed with the prospect of a nuclear
holocaust in December of 1961 he
announced to his congregation that he
had a prophetic dream in which the
entire American Midwest had been
destroyed in a nuclear conflagration
after reading a magazine article
entitled nine places in the world to
hide he took his young family on a trip
to one of them Belo Horizonte in Brazil
they stayed there for two years during
this time his distrust and personal
hatred towards the government of the
United States intensified he was
convinced that American political and
economic self-interest had brought the
world to the brink of destruction the
drains is returned to Indianapolis
December of 1963 Jim immediately made
plans to move his congregation who had
been waiting patiently for their leaders
return to another of the nine safe
places on the list Northern California
in the summer of 1964 the family along
with about a hundred and forty
congregants moved to the town of Ukiah
in the Redwood Valley area above San
Francisco over the next few months
church services were held in rented
church buildings and then at a ranch at
Ridgewood throughout the week Jim worked
as a high school teacher after three
years of steadily building up its
membership for Peoples Temple was
granted official standing by the
Christian Church disciples of Christ
Northern California Nevada region in
1968 the following February the People's
Temple Redwood Valley Complex opens the
complex included the Joneses home a
swimming pool childcare center old folks
homes the temple meeting place and a
ranch all of this of course was
completely integrated this little Garden
of Eden sat in the middle of a strictly
segregated Redwood Valley within a year
the People's Temple had expanded into
San Francisco buses were put on to
transport new parishioners there to
Redwood Valley for weekend services Jim
also took to the road by bus touring
from one city to the next winning new
converts in each place many of which
were so captivated by the charismatic
preacher
that they moved to the Redwood Valley
Ranch
people's temple experienced rapid
expansion during the 1970s however it
was also during this time that the
church received its first negative media
coverage a series of articles in the San
Francisco Examiner profiled the church
painting Jones as a false messiah who
had claimed to bring 43 people back from
the debt the authority structure of the
Church was also put under the spotlight
the examiner articles drew the interest
of other media outlets from then on
Jones came to view the media as the
enemy and an agent of the devil himself
things got worse when in 1973 eight
prominent members of the Peoples Temple
defected stories emerged of financial
abuse mind control and tax evasion in
response to the pressure brought upon
the church by the media and the
defectors Jim first proposed the idea of
mass suicide such a grand action would
establish the congruence as martyrs and
shame those who were out to get them as
for how however Jones's words were
nothing more than bluster it was during
the summer of 1973 that Jones made the
decision to relocate the People's Temple
to the South American country of Guyana
two months later he visited the country
in order to open negotiations to
purchase 27 thousand acres of land in
the Mathieu Ridge area near the
Venezuelan border the Guyanese
co-operative Republic was a socialist
country and for Jones who had passed
through on his return trip from Brazil
in 1963 it was an ideal haven the first
People's Temple members arrived in
Guyana in March of 1974 to begin the
mammoth task of clearing the jungle and
breaking grounds for construction on
what was to become Jonestown a year
later there were 50 Peoples Temple
pioneers in Guyana day and night they
worked to construct buildings and
establish a massive agricultural project
by 1977 Jonestown was an established
community but things were getting worse
back in California on Memorial Day 1977
along with 600 congregation members
Jones made an appearance at a
commemoration for suicides who had
jumped off San Francisco's Golden Gate
Bridge in his address on this day he
declared I have been in a suicidal mood
myself today so I have personal empathy
for what we are doing here today by now
there was renewed pressure on the church
from the American media on August the
1st 1977 an article appeared in
you west magazine that alleged members
had been beaten the church was rife with
financial Mis dealings and that Jim
Jones was nothing more than a charlatan
by the time the article hit the
newsstands James was already in Guyana
by September there were more than a
thousand people's temple members in
Guyana with only about 50 or so left in
the United States the sudden influx of
people placed severe strain on the
facilities of Jonestown however members
enthusiastically pitched in to extend
the village in order to accommodate the
demand three-quarters of the
transplanted residents were black with
the remainder being white Hispanic Asian
and Native American the task of feeding
housing and clothing the community was a
massive undertaking but the temple
members found a great sense of pride in
the feat that they were accomplishing a
utopian heaven on earth despite the
harsh conditions in the hard work the
people appeared in those first few
months to be genuinely happy back in
California former members began a
concerted attack on the People's Temple
a woman who had borne a child - Jones
sued for custody of the child's which
was living at the commune Jones refused
to even consider giving up the child
declaring that any attempt to take the
child would put the life of every member
of the People's Temple in jeopardy still
other defectors who had left children
behind also sued for custody following
this a declaration of human rights
violations committed by Peoples Temple
were issued by defectors to the media it
included the assertion that rehearsals
for mass suicide often took place at
people's temple a committee of concerned
relatives claims that Jonestown was
little more than a concentration camp
with armed guards constantly patrolling
and the residents continually subjected
to brainwashing forced labor and sleep
deprivation attempts were made to
pressure Congress to establish an
official investigation of Jonestown the
challenge was taken up by congressman
Leo Ryan representing the San Mateo
district of Northern California Ryan had
determined to lead a fact-finding
mission to Jonestown
in order to find out firsthand what was
going on there with reporters and
relatives in tow he flew into the
airport at nearby Georgetown on November
the 15th 1978 two days later they flew
to the airstrip at chi tumor and then
were driven by limousine into the jungle
towards Jonestown Jones had been
preparing the temple members for the
congressman's visit for weeks
every member knew that gods were
watching their every move they were
commanded to portray a glorious utopian
society role plays were conducted in
which the members were told exactly what
to say when spoken to you by reporters
any signs of dissatisfaction would be
harshly dealt with away from prying eyes
the congressman was warmly welcomed into
reception was held that first night Ryan
seemed genuinely impressed with the
organization and the order that he saw
but late into the night one of the
reporters who had come along with him
was secretly passed a note from a man in
the crowd the man he wanted to leave
with the congressman the next morning
the reporter showed the note of the
congressman Ryan brought the issue up
with Jones who declared that anyone was
free to come or go as they pleased this
prompted Ryan's you make a public
declaration that anyone who wanted to
leave with him at the end of the weekend
was most welcome over that weekend many
people came forward then on the
afternoon of the second day of the visit
a People's Temple member lunged at
congressman Ryan with a knife this event
soured the proceedings and the visitors
were intent on getting out as fast as
possible
[Music]
when the congressman's party left there
were 14 people's temple members with
them they got into two trucks and were
driven back to the airstrip however
almost immediately after they left
Jen's ordered a tractor and trailer
manned by armed bodyguards to follow
them just as the congressman reporters
and evacuees were about to board the
plane and head back to the safety of the
United States the truck and tractor
rolled onto the airstrip
it was at this point that Jones's guards
immediately opened fire with submachine
guns congressman Ryan and four others
were killed then one of these supposed
to defectors pulled out a handgun and
began shooting at those who had already
made their way onto one of the two
waiting planes the leader of the killer
guards immediately radioed back to Jones
and told them that the congressman was
dead it was at this point that Jones
immediately began talking to his
followers over a loudspeaker system he
told them that the congressman had been
killed and as a result the Soviet Union
who we had been looking to for salvation
would no longer take them in the
Americans were now certain to send in
armed forces to annihilate the People's
Temple
he drove fear into his followers by
telling them Americans would torture
their children raped their women and
brutalized their old people
the only dignified response he said was
to commit mass revolutionary suicide
[Music]
we didn't commit to it I we can enact a
revolutionary suicide protesting the
conditions of an engine main world large
barrels of cyanide laced kool-aid were
rolled out and the people began lining
up to lay down their lives in mass
protest when he heard people trying to
beg off Jones told them not to be afraid
they were simply stepping over to
another plane that day November the 18th
1978 nine hundred and fourteen members
of the People's Temple lay down their
lives Jones however did not succumb to
the cyanide laced kool-aid he was found
with a gunshot wound to his head it was
determined as being self-inflicted so I
really hope you enjoyed that bio
graphics video if you did don't forget
to subscribe to this channel for brand
new biographies every Monday and
Thursday also I've got another channel
it's called top tens on that channel as
you might have guessed from the name of
it we look at all sorts of interesting
top ten lists you can check it out
through the link on the screen now but
if you're looking for something else to
watch right now why not check out a
biography from the archives or indeed a
top tens video over there on the right
and as always thank you for watching